Just hours before flying off to Palm Beach,
Florida, and skipping the inauguration, Donald
Trump issued his final list of pardons and
he is not on the list and his children are
not on the list.
And we will talk a little bit about why momentarily.
A lot of speculation about that.
But the list does include a variety of individuals,
143 pardons, maybe most prominently.
Steve Benen, former White House chief strategist
and close adviser to Donald Trump, pardoned.
Now, the INS saying there is nothing more
Trump than the following.
Steve Bannon was arrested for felony fraud,
for defrauding build the wall donors.
These were pro Trump donors who wanted to
build the wall.
They donated to this, hey, give us money and
we'll build it.
And it was a total scam. Trump pardoned the
guy who scammed Trump's own supporters.
And if you needed any more proof that Trump
never cared about his supporters beyond how
they were useful to him politically, it is
the pardon of Steve Bannon.
How many times does Trump need to betray his
own supporters before they realized Trump
never cared about them to begin with?
Also pardoned Eliot Broider, former Republican
finance chair Kwame Kilpatrick, former Democratic
mayor of Detroit.
Randy Duke Cunningham, a former Republican
congressman.
Rick Renzi, former Republican Congressman
Robin Hayes, former Republican congressman
to rappers Lil Wayne and Chodak Black.
Notably missing from the list are pardons
for his family and pardons for himself.
And this apparently was the culmination of
a pretty dramatic couple of days where on
Saturday evening, this is a report from CNN.
Donald Trump was warned he had a long meeting
with his advisers on Saturday night.
And at that point, he still was leaning towards
pardoning in advance his children, his son
in law, maybe Rudy Giuliani and possibly even
himself.
And he was told, don't do it.
He was told if you pardon them and even yourself,
you will be placing yourself in a legally
perilous position.
It will convey the appearance of guilt.
It will potentially make you more vulnerable
to reprisals.
And indeed, Donald Trump acquiesced to that
and decided not to pardon his children and
not to pardon himself.
Some of these warnings came from White House
counsel Patrick Polony, as well as another
attorney, Eric Hirschmann, who was involved
in defending Trump in his first impeachment
trial.
And they all said to Trump, do not pardon
yourself, do not pardon your family.
Do not pardon any anybody in a prospective
manner unless you will list specific crimes.
And that was the concern.
A blanket preemptive pardon.
Had Trump said, well, I pardon Ivanka in advance
for campaign finance crimes.
As an example, this lawyer said that would
be better.
But it also is pointing a finger at specific
crimes you believe maybe they would be charged
with.
And in the end, Trump deciding I'm not going
to pardon any of them.
And even after Saturday, Trump kept bringing
this up, even after people around Trump thought
it's done, he's not going to pardon his kids
or himself.
Trump kept bringing it up, bringing it up,
bringing it up.
And the final meeting reportedly where Trump
finally was convinced, OK, I'm not going to
do it, took place on a Saturday evening.
And it's interesting as a general thing, because
Trump has often ignored advice given advice
given to him.
In fact, Trump ignoring advice given to him
as responsible for much of the trouble that
he got into during his presidency.
And there is a reason why defense attorneys
say, even if you think you had nothing to
do with the crime, it's better not to answer
questions to law enforcement.
Just call a lawyer and say, you don't want
to say anything.
There's a reason why that's the case.
And much of Donald Trump's trouble.
If we look back at his beleaguered four years,
much of that trouble caused by.
From choosing to speak rather than not by
Trump, Trump choosing to act rather than doing
nothing and just waiting for things to happen
without his involvement, and I don't know
if there is a lesson here.
I mean, the real lesson should be how on earth
how how can we prevent 75 million people from
being bamboozled by this guy and thinking
it's a good idea to elect him?
That's really the lesson that hopefully we
would learn and and somehow prevent in the
future.
I don't know if that's the case.
I don't know if that has been learned.
But the pardon list, the final pardon list
is out.
So this is the end of the Trump era and the
beginning of the Biden era.
Tomorrow, we will have the timing of today
made it difficult to have inauguration coverage
today on the show.
We'll be covering it live.
And maybe you're with us right now.
Maybe you watched it earlier with us.
Tomorrow, we will have coverage of the Biden
inaugural.
The initial speech scheduled to have a press
briefing already from trumpeting Biden's incoming
press secretary, Jen Psaki, tonight.
And then Joe Biden already scheduled today
to sign a bunch of executive orders, which
you can be sure we will be looking at tomorrow
and seeing if Joe Biden sticks to his promises.
So quick break.
Let me know your thoughts about what's good.
Excuse me, what's going on on Twitter, where
you can find me at David Pakman.
And then a bunch of final stories to tie up
some
loose ends coming up here, The David Pakman
Show at David Pakman Dotcom.